we did get a Korean barbecue last night
we did we we had that was crazy we um if
you're ever in LA
go to the prince they filmed the new
girl there they filmed past tense
um a little bit of trivia for you but no
honestly great Fried Chicken great
everything honestly they had Korean face
food
what else they have uh they had some
great fried rice
um yeah it was awesome
I'm still thinking about that meal
I genuinely woke up I thought that was a
screen cap for a good Fellas
unironically first of my eyes have been
so [__] that's good Fellas for like
maybe gen Z
this is doesn't he who's the guy in the
middle what's his name again I think
it's Nick Miller I think that's his does
he not kind of look like Joe Pesci right
there yeah he does
he definitely does just way bigger for
him
yeah yeah definitely yeah
yeah it's really oh yeah the guy on the
right's about ready to do a Chantix
commercial I tried to stop smoking with
Chantix remember those commercials right
before Ray Liotta died no you know he
has eyeliner on no he's like makeup on
he looks like a [__] scarecrow he's
like I can't believe I stopped smoking
with Chantix let's see it
do you think the industry knew he was on
his way out and they're like we got to
milk him for all his worth I think as
soon as Goodfellas stopped
as soon as it was done recording hmm
on his way out
really no he had some good roles after
what name two
come on he had um oh when he was in
observant report he's also in cocaine
bear there you go I can't believe it can
I get something I just want to hear his
voice
between
this is how disrespectful I have to quit
when you try to quit smoking with or
without Chantix you may have nicotine
withdrawal symptoms patch they didn't
work for me I didn't think anything was
going to work for me until I tried
Chantix
along with support helps you quit that's
right patches
I tried locking myself in my basement
before it didn't work the only thing
that worked for me was chanting what do
you have against Rayleigh I have nothing
I don't [__] care about Rayland the
dead little son of a [__]
what
what dude
it's not disrespectful dude he's dead he
doesn't even know I'm talking about it
what there's gonna be like two guys with
like good fellow posters in their room
they're gonna be like this is this is
[__] up I couldn't stop it looks like
it looks like he's like auditioning for
the Joker
that's what it looks like who is he
telling to stop there what movie Set is
he on I snuck onto Christopher Nolan's
set to record this chain ticks
commercial hey Ray now for this scene we
want you to you know pretend to do what
you used to do
as much as I thought it would
Jesus it's always worth these medical
commercials when they sit there and they
like show them eating like an Italian
dinner yeah you know they had to throw
that in because it's like because it's
like uh oh he wasn't good Fellas yeah
make it seem like it's a mob thing it'd
be so cute if we had him sir we served
some pasta carbonara right at the end of
the at the trailer it would feel just so
yo they branded him as a smoker how
[__] rude actor
father ex smoker Chantix also like how
they have like it's like this is also my
signature yeah
Mom I can't believe it what happened I
was in LA and I guess who I met Ray
Liotta you know what that would be
exciting if it was 1992. oh my god dude
I saw him on the Chantix commercial set
oh Ray Liotta the Chantix guy nah man
I'm pushing back dude I'd be hyped to
meet Ray Liotta I mean I would too
because he was in Good Fellas you know
no I would know him he's like did you
see my latest picture I'm like come on
Ray I would know him from Smoking Aces
Smoking Aces
oh God I haven't heard that movie
that's where I would know him from
[__] Smoking Aces dude you know it's
like the action Casino movie from 2006.
I mean look at all of these what is that
wait hold on Ed Sheeran what
come on Sin City what if my favorite
things to listening to when I'm taking
Chantix and putting it in my body is Ed
Sheeran shape of you is my favorite song
of all time I kind of going I'm going
into like a Stanley Stanley yeah Davis
readers I use Chantix they're both dead
can we it's true can you pull up that
music video that Ray Liotta's in who do
you think honestly let me ask you this
question can I ask you a question yeah
Ray Liotta's on his deathbed yeah and
you know he's like oh God what I
wouldn't do for a camel Crush yeah right
Next Room next room over
Stan Lee is also in his deathbed who
would win that fight
meaning like who's gonna Outlast no no
who in a fist fight who would win oh
Stanley or right you think right would
take Stan yeah
come on man you remember the only thing
that's stopping Stanley is age the thing
that's stopping Rey is his horrible
horrible addiction to cigarettes
his body is weaker than stands Stan I
mean has been around the block a lot
dearest reader I'm going to destroy you
that's what he says he goes over to Ray
Liotta while rayleo is like laying his
bed he just starts [__] strangling
them go to sleep Ray I don't want to
sleep stand I want to take my Chantix
come with me yeah we're going together
so we're going together Ray you want
Chantix Ray you want Chantix here I'll
give you what's his last one
he's your last mouth right in his
[__] mouth
there you go good night go to sleep I'm
writing a new comic book right now Ray
bro I want a Chantix man Ed Sheeran and
what is that rudimental rudimental
bloodstream but I just want to see what
Raley has to do how did they get Ray
Liotta he must be so busy
well he doesn't have much to do now it's
insane to think that somewhere on this
planet his ghost is haunting somebody
yeah well I think you're have you
thought about that getting haunted by
Ray Liotta's ghost I think I'd be fine
I'm I have nothing but respect for him I
think if he haunts you he's going to be
[__] your [__] up dude I told my life
Good Fellas that ain't enough man that's
enough
after all the slander you just [__]
put out on it could he honestly if he
was sitting there he's like well what
did you see
I don't know did you see smooth
detective no but I saw Smoking Aces Ray
and I loved you and that and I loved you
in Black yeah the four minutes of screen
time you had was awesome yeah I love the
one scene you didn't smoke in Aces if
you were gonna make a movie and you knew
that Ray Liotta was gonna be your main
actor
what would that movie be
such a good question
I think that I would try to have him be
uh he'd be a dentist
hmm my dentist it would be a horror film
where it's him Ray Liotta's a dentist
and uh he comes in and he's just like
torturing people the whole time okay and
it's like him like [__] dig it into
your tooth oh sorry did I go too far
down how about this how about
um he's a like a a serial killer plumber
you know I think that was him probably
for just a period in his life
before Smoking Aces came into his life
I'm here to fix your pipes just showing
crack
yeah
and turns around yeah wow he turns
around with all that eyeliner on
thank you